which how different will the offense
have to be depending on who the
quarterback might be or will they
basically be doing
much of the same things
yeah i think to your point earlier i
think it could vary based on who the
quarterback is
we've always tried to look closely at
the strengths of our players
what they do well
and
we'll build a little bit around
that player accordingly and and that's
something that that
that we did when drew first arrived here
and we would do with with either of
these two players
fairly obvious point but an important
one to emphasize as the new orleans
saints move toward picking between
taysom hill and jameis winston there
will be different plays
based upon the skill sets of the two
individuals taysom hill a guy that you
can do a lot more quarterback running
with and uh jameis winston a more
traditional quarterback so yeah and and
some coaches dread the idea of that
because you basically have to maintain
two separate playbooks right right sean
payton loves it he loves it because his
players know how to run the place and
they'll deal with the stress of having
two different playbooks and he'll be
able to go to whichever one he wants
based upon whoever he decides is going
to be the quarterback for the season or
for a month or for a game it's why he's
one of the great coaches of the era he's
definitely one of the greatest offensive
minds in the history of the sport it's
all that because he's not one of those
coaches that's like this is my offense
and this is what i do and you guys are
gonna fit into that okay great i bet you
if he had that approach he would have
been fired years ago but he evaluates
his team his players you know the
current status of his quarterback and
then he formulates the offense around it
you know so he's always been able to do
that and that's what the great
offensive minds do with like taysom and
jameis winston
you know seven on seven today the past
plays will look exactly the same there's
going to be no difference they get on an
11-11 portion of the practice yes it's
going to look different taysom hill is
going to have some of those quarterback
design run plays and things like that
but there's no doubt i mean depending
he'll
he'll toy with all his different ideas
for both guys throughout training camp
and as he gets through training camp and
gets a better feel for who's in the
leader house to be the starter and all
that
he's going to continue to grow that part
of the offense oh it's taysom hill wait
let's grow the quarterback runs to play
action passes everything off of it and
continue to get that better if it's
jameis winston yeah they'll probably be
more of a drop back pass you know
surgical but yet down the field attack
that he didn't have the last few years
with drew brees that he'll be able to
add in the office with jameis winston
that way so that's where it'll be
different but i bet you he kind of loves
the challenge of this
an example of why the point you made
about system is so spot on tony dungy
tells the story of interviewing for a
new offensive coordinator during the
time that he was in tampa bay and simple
question what's your plan for mike all
starting work done
and there were candidates who said
i got my system oh
they run my system that's not the right
answer no the right answer is you tailor
your system right to suit who you have
right and that's what payton is is such
a genius at doing among many other
things peyton also addressed yesterday
the receivers because it's michael
thomas plus
who knows here he is talking about the
guys that they have available to catch
the passes from whoever the quarterback
may be
sean you've spoken in the past but like
the emphasis you guys put on development
um
how would you kind of assess that uh the
development of that young receiver core
kind of behind mike thomas um
guys coming up the last couple years
they're doing well they're doing very
well and and part of that was
you know a number of those guys played
more snaps last year because of injury
and
uh and i'm encouraged i i like the way
that room is is
coming together um
you know there are a few guys that got
more snaps a year ago because of some of
our depth issues and and i think that's
that's helped them
yeah hey that's one of the benefits of
michael thomas missing so much time
last year other guys getting a chance to
step up now emmanuel sanders not there
anymore he's in buffalo but you got some
of these other guys going to have to
step up and get it done and they're
going to be working with a new
quarterback this is
going to be one of the biggest
challenges
for sean payton of his career and i
would assume he finds it chris
incredibly invigorating i i would think
so too i mean you know usually great
coaches do they like these kind of
challenges and you challenge their
creative part of their brain to come up
with ideas and all that yeah it's it's a
little bit of a
unproven part of the roster right now
yeah michael thomas we know his star
stud okay trey kwon smith i think is a
guy that's up and coming there's no
doubt about that they got deontay harris
who they can kind of use as a weapon
type guy
i would expect to see him a little bit
and i'm missing one guy
there's the marquez callaway's guys yeah
they got so they got some guys that kind
of gotta develop as we go
and you know one of the things that like
when i look at that too
and again this is just a base like june
thought right but when i look at that
and we talk about receivers and
everything like that that to me again is
another thing where i look at it i think
it's an advantage taste some hill there
because taysom hill's ability to run
can
give some of these
other receivers not named michael thomas
maybe some more favorable looks and
match-ups and make things life a little
easier on them than oh hey it's jameis
winston and they're going to drop back
and pass and we know it's going to be
that too so that would be one thing that
at least comes across my mind when you
evaluate the saints roster in this
situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports